dental care the sponsors of this next
segment are dedicated to helping you
achieve the smile aesthetic you've
always wanted and here's how they do it
it's estimated that over 175 million
americans have at least one missing
tooth so comprehensive dental care is
here to educate that population on their
best options my practice is focused
mainly on dental implants and
single tooth
restorations and full arch
replacement of teeth
i've been doing dental implants for 25
years in other words dr hendrickson
knows what he's doing he's also one of
the national full art restoration
trainers for hybridge dental lab which
helps his practice focus on comfort
aesthetics and function let's talk
aesthetics the beauty of the high bridge
is that it's supported typically
with six implants in the upper jaw
and five implants in the lower jaw which
allows us to make a
basically a bridge
that includes 12 teeth it gives a
patient a full complement of smile and
how does dr hendrickson go about
designing your hybrid smile we take a
lot of photographs we we stand in front
of the patient we watch them talk this
is why the full arch restoration is a
better option than single implants had
one lady a number of years ago that came
in she had had
15 single implants done
over the past 20 years
as one tooth would break
they'd take it out put an implant in
the gum tissue melt away another tooth
would break
she would
even though she had all of her teeth for
the most part she continued to have
problems hybridge allows that finished
look while staying authentic to your
look we have multiple shades to look at
look for
we go through we can go through a very
tedious long process
of trying these in to make sure they're
absolutely perfect they want this one
tooth just rotated just ever so slightly
we can do that and your new smile will
stand the test of time they don't absorb
stain
they're easy to care for which is really
another cool thing when we're talking
about
the hygienics of this okay people want
to be able to keep these clean right
hybridge is designed to be hygienic we
go over
how to care for these with the patient
they don't have to ever come out of the
mouth to be cleaned these are made so
that they just
they they touch the gum tissue they're
easily you can floss underneath them
we use water pick we show you how to
cleanse them according to dr hendrickson
the process of putting the hybrid in is
also relatively pain free patients
typically say the first 18 hours are the
worst with some soreness the next day
when we put these in the patient's
mouths
they look 10 years younger
you know if you look at somebody's face
and eyes
that has dental problems
it may sound cliche but sometimes they
kind of come in kind of lifeless because
they
they're not they don't like their smile
they're not happy with it so they're not
smiling
and when we can give them that smile
back their whole face lights up
thank you comprehensive dental care for
sponsoring that segment they're located
in henderson and for more information
call
702-735-3284 or head to
envydentist.com we will be right back